what's up reject nation I'm John Greg
isn't that funny we are going to watch
Episode six season three of stranger
thingies spiel time subscribe to the
real rejects and click that notification
bell see we notify when our next video
is up for stranger things Oh Watson
Watson I'm trying to be a professional
trying to be a professional Eric over at
nerd chronic thank you for editing this
video down for us YouTube only allows
for 10 minutes worth of footage so our
stream along for a surrender things all
going over at our patreon page and that
patron we do stream along for many shows
that includes Gotham haunting of Hill
House Cobra Kai season 2 we cover
several shows were there stream alongs
and reaction highlights included that is
supernatural attack on titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and one punch man Eric over
a nerd chronic he has his own podcast
forever podcasts are found including on
YouTube
he's done work for people like Iman snow
aqus on the movie trivia Schmo talents
watch this where they get caught
oh no no I didn't feel that they'd get
confident so they don't wanna bet
happening oh man one day I have a strobe
light warning no that is so gross
oh wow you
always by windows
Oh
Steve's gonna Snake Plissken Stinson for
you're gonna get something Russian
torture [ __ ] oh great she looks exactly
like her mother and father
this door is open now
tell your lover
I can't believe I'm gonna die in a
secret Russian basement steep inherent
it was first period Tuesdays and
Thursdays so you were always late oh
yeah you always have the same breakfast
do you remember me from that
it's not a seeing stranger things of
Steve as he as a skit he Lucy got to
kick one ass trust me
Oh
the source
do you think you're so smart but
complicates scoop ice cream turning back
to your coat in a day and now they're
gonna come in here commando style guns
ablaze and kick your sorry ass back a
brush you're gonna be two pieces of
toast
he's stash
like a movie
oh no where she trapped you
and now you
all this time who has been building it
building
you serve as your strapless
I always like gathering hosts and
they're all bringing the mind flirt of
life
oh she's
yeah they're deaf
Oh
oh man
what an episode what an episode
I was so awesome music and everything I
was great all right so really quick the
mind flutters never come into like full
physical form in any of stranger things
yet right I want to be make sure I'm a
hundred percent clear on that yeah so
this so at 7:00 they're talking about
like what it's all been building to hey
this is the season alone is doing just
such a great job on build up Oh miss
Pressy job on how to do a proper build
up for a second I thought at the
beginning of the show with a hopper
doing him the keys at like oh my god
they're dragging this out but that I'm
like I never mind they're being smart
about this it was that did you all your
writers take a break for just this one
yeah so the mind flare so what they're
doing is finding all these bodies that
essentially are all forming into the
physical manifestation of the mind flare
to come into the real world and take
over that's like the shadow monster
taking nasty physical form that is crazy
that is disturbing how do you defeat
that it's like oh my god what does that
mean next all those people are dead why
don't you have to dive into Billy's core
memories though in order to find I think
because if we go back a few episodes
Bailey says to the girl like go to your
happy place or something to block out
what was happening to her so I think
that's what the mind flayer uses to
block out like hide where he is once I
so
but don't draw too much attention so
essentially I haven't here is really
really hard these are kind of the four
cats here they're all trying to
socialize and during this take the big
progress big progress back to a few
episodes ago Billy's telling Heather
when he's like doing everything to her
go to your happy place and I think
that's when he tells her that so I think
that's the mind flayers thing it's like
go to your happy memory the haidle where
I am kind of feeds off of the pain
correct up seat ball yeah it's like
focus on your happiest memory to keep
yourself distracted while I root myself
yeah that's of you and she also needed I
think yeah I mean that was the plan she
came up with was like if I can trace
Billy's memories back to when this
happened to him you know and it just so
happened to have uncovered your
childhood memories to understand why you
are the way you are which knowing
stranger things I might come into play
with actually being able to defeat this
or lace at least getting through to
Billy in some capacity you dr.
Montgomery back for Season four if they
get the mind flayer like separate back
into individual forms like do those
people get to come back if their bodies
have been right that's a good question
there's even the point where he's
telling her he's explaining to her we're
gonna destroy the whole world and he's
crying when telling her this he's crying
he was like we're gonna kill you we're
gonna kill your friends you can see him
crying oh I mean since the first since
the second episode you brought up the
internal struggle that Billy's going
through like when he doesn't kill Karen
even though he's clearly tempted to kill
Karen can they show that visual cue
smashes her head in and he decides to
like get away from me go so there's
still a good person inside of him or
there are all hosts so there should be
some element of yeah him still in there
so yeah maybe they can pull him out or
maybe he will die her rope I mean this
episode was just a full on just this is
like epic stranger things territory yeah
from fighting
mini mine flavor at the hospital oh yeah
because this is like an hour-long
episode so fighting like the mini mine
flare at the hospital and then getting
to the very end with going into the
coolest way to explore someone's
memories ever yeah I'm so visually
beautiful oh yeah totally what I mean
this episode all that stuff in the lab
with a truth serum and and Steven Robin
like bonding and the dust and coming
back to ya and stuff like that like I I
well they had great character moments
with the uncovering the true history
Robin and Steve but then even having
character moments with Erica and Dustin
like the whole nerd discovery yeah or
Billy even you find Billy's back yeah
he's history like through the memory
there's a lot of character development
see why Mike's on edge because he's in
love with 11 yeah he finally admits we
finally found out that he loves 11 yeah
I would never have guessed it shocking
it's like the first episode oh yeah so I
think they're calling I I forget the
character's name oh they say Owens I
don't like the professor that's Paul
Rice's character right the guy who was
working on a will and in season 2 I
believe so that would make sense that be
cool if he came back seems like every
time there's a problem joy steps in to
rush things along season 3 trope of
Joyce yeah
do you like no no no yeah you want her
to do all your customer service calls on
your behalf cuz she's gonna get [ __ ]
yeah
I mean it was very rewarding to watch
her just like boss that dude at the desk
yeah you know because especially with
what they've all been through you know
that there's gotta be some kind of
provision for their relationships
whatever the institution is now it seems
like I'm gonna get some really cool
showdown at the fair and then obviously
something Crazy's gonna go down at the
star court mall that's been like the
main thing teased and like promo images
and then you know just put the way the
shows and go start a quarter mall maybe
I didn't like Don with the dead stuff
I'm still having it so with the whole
Russians though are they implied that
they opened up
do they open up the portal that allowed
all this to happen the way how the mind
flare has been able to get back in is it
through what the Russians have been
doing or is it just gonna be sages at
the complicating is it there's gonna be
some they haven't opened it yet so so
maybe the Russian thing is gonna come
into play with putting the mind flutter
back away yeah so it's just a very
convenient thing yeah maybe that they
intended to help but maybe they're yeah
it's like they talked about that whole
thing with the key like there's got to
be some kind of reverse key right yeah
so yeah maybe
Alexei will be a hero at the end of the
day I told you that first time I saw him
I was like she's gonna be a good guy
eventually isn't he stuff you just tell
he would be I think the main Russian bad
guy who's doing all the talking is a
little over the top
Oh Russian bed guy pretty exaggerated
performance yeah but no Dustin saved the
day now they're all gonna finally come
in here they're gonna break out of there
then the whole gangs gonna get assembled
have some awesome Star Court Fair
excitement I'm excited for it we can
talk about this season as a whole and
then Cary Elwes is gonna close the
portal yeah season four is gonna come
back as a good guy alright guys well
make sure to subscribe to the real
rejects click the notification best and
we notify when our next stranger things
reaction video is up check us on patreon
and patron of the day shout out for a
man named X self-loathing X this guy I
think he just pledged a couple days ago
and he did say he's watching stranger
things on this post that we put out on
patreon and you know for shoutouts I
like to give a really you know a
personal shout out so I sent him a
message try to get some info by the time
of filming this he hasn't gone back to
me he's one of those folks so I just
imagined this guy I don't even know his
actual name where he's from or anything
he's probably just sitting alone in his
room so I first punch you in the face
self-loathing
it's going a cuckoo Carter better shout
out if it was more on top of my life if
I had what better way of checking my
messages of patreon instead of this
really demeaning shout-out that Greg
gave me in the stranger things video now
I just feel dumb and I'm a loser
that's a catch I hope you don't love
yourself as much as you did a minute ago
because we love you tension and release
love you had that specifically there he
knows his cue so do you know that I
don't really mean that
- well trinket depressions a serious
thing so quit being a [ __ ] in your room
and get back to me I hope that still
lets you feel encouraged to stay pledged
for another couple more months my friend
check your messages buddy yeah I hope
you don't just joking see you guys